hey guys don't think oh that's gay we're
gonna basically what we planned on
cooking something but I don't know
what's going to happen this is actually
Matt's idea because you told me this was
mass idea and now we're gonna yeah I
just think they look delicious
I didn't say you had an angle but I'm
glad I only came over specifically
because you guys said and we're going to
so what we're gonna make is an ice cream
sandwich with ice cream with a cookie
cookie dough ice cream sandwich with it
so I'm calling Kate or baby
here's the problem this is all ice cream
yeah just like that
five comes from the internet and bolita
it look like it was a good washer ah
that's like one cookie sandwich okay
Thank You Morgan maybe have anything off
Jamie over there over there you like not
even in the screen see I was a myth Oh
mom and none of them observing he's
observing master gonna Sam you all right
so first step is what kind of ice cream
is that it's go go go but I want you
were drunk on cookie dough if you even
know or do it double wait double cookie
dough
wait are you making your own cookie Oh
whispers yeah
I'm not sure what's up oh I should kind
of vibrate kept you know
wow I had not you know I suppose hey
you're not supposed to get cookie dough
it's like good it does matter as all
know here's what we're gonna to do
better model try I'll keep a slice
oh my god it was freaking fantastic it's
not exactly fantastic what we don't
really I like bread I design here don't
worry I don't forget concerting you're
mad you look so good right now growl
what yeah you just gotta like it cuz
it's so good Fredo you go Bravo
irritability yeah I misspoke on two
pieces like I'm talkin about
okay what are you doing what are you
doing wait girl thanks mom
they had Jenna knows of cereal we're on
the train the cooks baby I like you know
make cooker not me what do you maybe
can't wait like it you know I got
everywhere dude the Internet well maybe
don't use it well we're not baking it
okay
nobody's it about oh my god maybe that's
a tile oh it's gonna go okay what you
did this plate was your idea I have no
idea I want to make it pick up the game
you go hmm you flip the tray so the flat
surface wait wait right we're gonna well
we just were this is mashed into a
circle come on and just stick the ice
cream and yeah yeah that's how you how
do we eat you're not cooking okay I'm
not okay
Matt somebody anybody who would like to
pour the ice cream on here hey let Matt
dude you look so good you got a nice
come on we want a good-looking person to
do kind of get we there's only one in
this room wait Matt go crybaby for their
drums yeah so uh Matt all right what
no offense Jenna but Matt is the
best-looking person here today
Oh God Matt is going to use this spoon
scoop
he's going to scoop the ice cream to put
it onto there and then we have a dinner
stare now here we go Matt so since we
need a lot of press windows account
look at what an acting fee animal it
looks so good and edible
oh I said well here here's the thing
gotta get real good okay whatever it
pretends like no microwave no you don't
want to cook those little more slick it
10 sec you better hurry up listen man
there's a technique to scooping ice
cream I've been doing it for years
alright that's a great ok good job guys
would give me a minute
that's done I'll dispose of that
replacement where we of cookie
something went wrong with this you know
it looks just like the picture this is
best on Twitter is that the one oh my
god where's the picture pajama show to
you today they look really good I found
hot you're gonna see yeah see they're
wrong thank you probably shouldn't try
this but I think it's gonna be a push it
down a little bit oh no we all tell them
while they make the sandwich we could
get some attention okay put that don't
look that's awesome ice cream on you put
the Commission up a little bit our dude
we dive in and this is incredible oh my
god did you guys watch for watching yes
it I just lost it
so who wasn't probably oh god that's
awful videos your face so none of us are
going to Cabo cover all the toys listen
Nicolino and ice cream is way better
than the rock I like it so much I
couldn't pay so someone did not wash
their hands he was here your pet of
Jenna you're just coming in half versus
Pinterest worthy I'm getting a deal
look at that look at your Center if
anybody eats that out give you Matt
you're literally getting the same thing
yeah but I'm you know listen I already
throw it up tomorrow on the street
thanks for watching I hope you
enjoy this video I don't think that you
should follow our directions but man oh
this is fantastic the ice cream is
fantastic I'm not either probably know
anything at home this is a solar go try
it on it's a bake it down so there
happens JB is the only good buddy of
this there's only one good-looking
driver and that's Matt alright bye
wonder what just happened
oh my god bless so I was running Dumas's
with my wall working on a piece take a
run don't know 600